Thank you to dollar Shave Club for
sponsoring this video.
Okay,
let's go five minutes,
sir.
Let's make some sandwiches.
I think it's done.
Let's see,
maybe two hours
cooking and cooked food or almost as
ubiquitous in our films,
Sdr aspects of our daily lives,
but whether you see cooked food as
nothing more than fuel to keep your body
from buying give it does me.
No,
no,
no.
Get that out right now.
Or as a piece of art that almost doesn't
deserve to be eaten.
Oh my God.
People eat because they're hungry.
I want to make food and makes people
stop eating for eight good filmmaker or
writer.
The Cuc Ennis food are always more than
just a nutter prop in a scene or a cheap
way to cover up a lifeless story with
some pleasant ICANDY.
That's a chef's knife.
Look to hire
the role of the chef as the passionate
mediator of raw nature to high culture
has served as an APP allegory for the
process and frustrations of the
Hollywood filmmaker bay.
Like the filmmaker to chef is often
depicted as a visionary artist of sorts
who's creativity has been shackled by
his superiors and now suddenly you're
going to be an audience will be an
artist on your own time or who believes
his workers under appreciated?
No,
she's the Philistines.
I'm going live on a dog to add or overly
critiqued by those who don't have
anything to add themselves for the chef
to overcharge us for his insecurity and
lack of imagination,
but beyond sly allegories the ubiquity
of Kooks and hot dishes and cinema can
also reveal something meaningful about
our humanity and his boot catching fire.
How cooking made us human primatologist
Richard Wrangham made to controversial
but thought provoking claim that this is
the act of cooking that is the primary
distinguishing feature of humanity.
And it has played an enormous part in
our evolution as a species.
Fucking unbelievable.
We are tied to our adaptive diet of
cooked food.
And the results pervade our lives from
our bodies to our minds.
We humans are at a cooking apes your
creatures of the flame,
and so we should indeed been our
humanity on Kooks.
In Ratatouille,
we can see this notion of cooking as a
civilizing process play out in a
transformation of remy to country rat
and to a five star chef in the culinary
capital of the world.
Contrary to his fellow rats,
remy chooses to walk on two feet,
cares about hygiene,
self control,
just fork it down and learns how to read
all because of his passion for cooking.
It's only one way to weed a brace of
Kone,
but if cooked food can be seen as being
universally connected to civility films
can also use this to show us its
opposite.
What did you say?
Sorry.
Get
an old boyd.
The main character of the story,
he eats a life on cooked octopus both in
a desire to touch something living,
but also to reveal as d humanize state.
After 15 years of isolated imprisonment,
he'll fight back on that menu bar,
but consuming raw food can also serve
more practical purposes.
The raw can come to be synonymous with
gaining natural strength and adapting
oneself.
Do an uncivilized environment.
Similarly to rules and expectations of a
warm meal can be broken to acquaint to
civilized with the realities of an
uncivilized world.
It's like a piece of chalk called bring
it all back,
but this desire for the natural and the
Ra can also showcase once in capability
of building and maintaining civilized
human relationships.
Food can also be used to indicate it
perceived level of Savitri on a societal
level,
be it in our own community or in those
of others depicting morally despicable
or highly unconventional foods as
markers of uncivility setting more
culture protagonists apart from the
exotic and wild world which they
inhabit,
and that when taken to its extreme,
can degenerate into perhaps the ultimate
symbol for Savitri.
Right.
We're going to fucking eat your ass.
This in turn can be used as a tool to
completely break a character
or it can serve as a menacing and highly
disturbing form of antagonism and in
humanity.
Yeah.
Nope.
Okay.
Steven Manel argue set another essential
element of civilized food consumption is
a regulated appetite.
The civilized don't merely eat out of
the immediate hunger,
but collectively decide when to do so.
Together.
I love you darling girl.
And so it dinner can be to see enough
civilized harmony,
but it can also be used to invert this
harmony,
revealing tensions between polar
opposite characters and even devolving
into gluttony and depravity.
Often mockingly depicting in our
problems of characters and society's
alike.
And if over abundance and wastefulness
of food are connected to uncivility.
So with scarcity,
you're going to die for some chickens.
Just like in real life,
a lack of food can be utilized to bring
about the deepest forms of humanity in
people.
And at times the very darkest aspects
will be characters,
personality,
cooked food can be a battle ground for
perceived moral superiority and higher
social status and will be serving those
who own the food,
have the most of it,
or have the final say in how it should
be prepared,
hold a sense of power over others.
And so did we.
Zenes of entire countries can come to be
the objects of a bitter and at times
hilarious rivalry.
Similarly,
an over abundant fees can shoot agreed
and hypocrisy.
UV,
tyrannical government and the
meticulously crafted dessert can be used
to reveal the roofless and unpredictable
nature of a character who likes to hide
behind a gentle masco.
Be civilized friend.
Send the deposit
doctor
I said are totally booked to it.
Nine.
Perfect.
See you then.
Food is a status symbol we can use to
impress others with and you Seville our
own real personality.
Well,
you have to promote general social
concern.
It's a symbol through which we can gauge
the matter of control a character has
over his life and it means through which
to maintain an artificial sense of
civility juxtaposed against a contrast.
In reality you'll be character or of the
outside world.
Yeah,
we made it dude,
but just as cooked food can height
faults,
any person or society.
It can also serve as a symbol of freedom
and hope.
I think it's going daddy cooking and
cooked food as civilized.
There's can be used to bring people
together.
I know the thing about good food.
It brings folks together from all walks
of life.
We had our people with wildly varying
personalities,
sculpture or even those in an active
state of war II,
belly well filled functions as one of
the prime factors in creating a
civilized environment.
It is perhaps no wonder then that we've
chosen.
The dinner table is one of the prime
places from where intimate relationships
can grow and bloom.
Now you'll know
do we eat?
The good food is to be close to God,
meticulously cooked food like an
exceptional book.
A painting or a great piece of cinema
can have a transformative effect on
characters and people alike.
Bringing back memories this instantly
and brings you back to my time and
taking our breaths away in a moment of
peaceful bliss.
It's so fucking good.
I should kill you.
And Cinema as well as in the real world.
Cooking and cooked food reveal their
connectedness with argument.
He by making dose who engage in it,
more human,
bringing us closer to ourselves and we
can link old passions and relationships.
This uniquely human trait has gone hand
in hand with the evolution of our
species from a wild group of primates
and two cultured civilizations who owe a
great deal to the very first chefs of
our race for filmmakers.
The interest and usage of cooking and
food and film is and perhaps ought to be
not just limited to an allegory about
the frustrations of art,
but it's about cooked food as one of the
main civilizing drives of our species
because the food we eat in our daily
lives and especially to food characters,
Cook and consume and movies is in a lot
of ways universally connected to the
overarching topics of all story,
who we are as people and what it means
to be human.
Okay,
thank you all for watching and now onto
a special reveal.
Most of us have our daily grooming
routines.
Unless you're like me and you don't buy
new razors because you hate going out to
buy grooming products and you actually
start to believe that you could
definitely grow a sick ass beard and
said,
well,
guess what?
You're wrong.
This is what happens when you don't
shave.
This is what you're going to look like.
Thank God.
Dollar Shave club intervened and send me
dare $5 daily essential starter kit that
honestly has some of the best grooming
products I've ever used.
The starter kit comes with their
executive razor,
which includes their premium,
weighty handle and full cassette of four
cartridges.
Besides that you get their famous
transparent shaving butter,
a set of one wipe charlies infused with
aloe vera and Kemah meal.
And lastly,
my favorite,
the amber lavender body wash,
which cleans your skin and we'll leave
you smelling like you just came back
from a trip to the fields of southern
France.
Uh,
it's honestly great stuff and as you can
see,
dollar shave club has done wonders and
treating my pubic facial hair and it can
do so for you two for just $5.
You can get this exclusive one month
start a kid sent right to your door with
free shipping@dollarshaveclub.com slash
storytellers.
After that replacement cartridges are
sent for just a few bucks a month.
Don't become this guy.
Get some help,
get dollar shave club and help out our
channel by getting their starter kit
delivered right to your door or any of
their many other products like
toothpaste and Hair Gel at dollar shave
club.com/storytellers they are the main
reason we could make this video and
helping them means helping us.
Thank you.